when the Earth was young it most likely
had a ring of rock debris around it
[Music]
four and a half billion years ago
another planet Thea
giant impact sent a ring of matter
hurtling into the Earth's orbit but it
didn't stay like that for long
the rocky debris soon formed another
Celestial body the one we now call the
Moon
having planetary Rings visible in the
sky would look way more spectacular than
just one gray rock right
maybe but if our planet got beautiful
Rings like these tomorrow
much of life on Earth might not survive
the renovation process
necessarily take another Collision to
form rings around the Earth
we could just crumble the moon and for
that we'd only need to move it a little
closer